okay former acting deputy secretary of
homeland security under president trump
ken cuccinelli
joins me now um let's go through those
one at a time ken good to have you with
us
uh they they said the vice president
said you can't go to the border because
of covet issues
um what do you think about that yeah
well i
i think it's just one more smoke screen
i mean i think
maybe it was just her answer off the top
of her head
but they are taking positive testing
illegal immigrants with no
identification and putting them on
public transportation
by which i mean transportation shared
with
american citizens to send them all over
the country
and by the way the federal government's
paying for it so
if there are covet issues that that
they're afflicting the american people
with
um or if they're not so bad
uh why can't she go visit uh you know
this is just
tangled in so many different ways it's
really just a bad excuse i mean let's
just
call it what it is okay it's a bad
excuse
it doesn't fit and especially uh part of
the reason at the border we have covet
issues is they're inviting in
hundreds of thousands of people here
illegally
who are coming up in petri dish-like
conditions
in the back of trailers with they're
staying in stash houses
with other people who they don't know
needless to say
precautions aren't being taken i mean
it's just it's just ridiculous on top of
ridiculous
unless she's just concerned about her
own safety
she was vaccinated we all saw that um
you know
i think she put it out on social media
so she she was definitely
vaccinated um you know it it just raises
so many questions because
it's saying if you are accepting people
into the country
right and you want to take
responsibility for them which is what
jan zaki was saying you know we're
trying to manage as well we're trying to
make sure that they're moved to
facilities well this administration has
been so
careful and by the polls effective in
dealing with covet
so why aren't they you know saying look
we've got a process
everyone is tested we're quarantining
people for this amount of time
before we put them on these buses i mean
it seems like a
real oversight and a real contradiction
to their other policies where this where
this virus has been concerned
well it is an i don't know that it's an
oversight that suggests that they
that they aren't aware of it and and and
said whoops uh
i think they don't care um they the
because anything along the lines that
you described
all of which makes sense slows down the
in
processing and they seem determined
to facilitate not to slow down
not to check not to segregate by health
purposes
any of these folks it's amazing as fast
as they possibly can
i'm just thinking about how you know the
contrast between what we're talking
about
and the fact that the president is
wearing his mask he's been vaccinated
and telling everyone that fourth of july
parties might be
on might not happen because not enough
people
are are making sure that they don't get
coveted so i mean it's just there's such
a dichotomy
um before on the way out here because i
gotta go and i do thank you for being
here
uh mr cuccinelli this is a picture of
kamala harris's book
um in one of these facilities it's
folded up on the uh
you know on a little blanket i think we
have that picture um this is what greets
all the kids as they come in and i think
it's you know perfectly
nice that they are getting a book to
read on the way in but um
it's the book written by the vice
president and um
so anyway take away from that that would
be that it sure
looks like a a really low level
and petty conflict of interest by the
vice president
ken cuccinelli thank you very much good
to see you today sir